i was kind of pissed off as well that
like all of these kids are like 13 14.
yeah i was like why not
why just make them seventeen it would
make this story so it's a little weird
that you felt so much makes so much more
sense but here's the thing isn't it
weird that you felt that about that show
and yet you see hanayama kana who's 14
years old you're like perfectly
understandable have a nice day because
it makes for some reason it like it
checks out like i'm like i don't know
i don't doubt it right because he never
asks me once to like actually believe
this world is a real world yeah yeah it
just completely is like listen bro this
is literally like the the equivalent of
an internet forum like debate where
you're like can goku beat saitama like
that is back
it never once asked you to be invested
in this world that's true whereas like
tokyo revenge for me felt like it was
trying to it was trying to get me to get
invested in the gangs and the culture
but at the same time how are you gonna
make me believe that this is how 13 year
old and 14 odds react that they like
that they drive by motorcycles they do
all this [ __ ] and it's like they're
willing to like rob and kill each other
listen
if you made these kids 18 they can still
be in school yeah all of this would
still make sense and it's like just just
do that wow that's like that's like
basically 90 of anime where it's like
they don't need to be that age because
nobody actually their age actually acts
like them this is one where i actually
felt like it was to a massive detriment
that they were like super young
and this every single player just made
it unbelievable
not so unbelievable but like it made it
so to the fact that you're like it's
constantly asking you to just have this
level of disbelief right yeah to give it
like okay i guess this is how 14 year
olds would react and respond to this
situation and it's like just just add on
four years they're still in school this
can work in college it all still works
yeah the universe totally works it could
work if when you're an adult as well
yeah yeah and now they can ride
motorcycles no question about it this is
in japan yeah no one is breaking the
laundry
people don't even like they they they
the only law they break is stealing
umbrellas that's literally it that's all
they do they don't do that
no one is gonna how the [ __ ] are they
gonna get a motorcycle at 13 here i feel
like when i like the last time i felt
that like when when i felt like the
characters just weren't acting their age
at all uh was when i watched erased i
was gonna
race the race was just like man these
five-year-olds how old were they like
five seconds
they're like nine they're like nine year
olds i feel like you're like three yes
using the forms of relativity and
quantum mechanics we can actually
predict when we will
they're like more capable than like like
like veteran detectives in the force and
all this [ __ ] and i'm just like bro
these are like nine-year-olds and
they're acting like that
that's why i just couldn't get into a
race there's the exact same thing where
i'm like this nine-year-old like girl is
like solving mysteries that like [ __ ]
you know we've talked all about the
asian stuff and i do understand that
like a lot of shows i don't give a [ __ ]
like it's totally fine it's fiction it's
whatever it doesn't matter yeah but like
again there are some shows like erased
where i feel like
doing this is just completely to the
detriment of the show and it makes you
sense suspend belief beyond reasonable
doubt yeah i don't know
there's a lot of one of the shows where
i'm like this is just stupid i mean like
there's also like your line in april as
well where a big thing that took me out
of the show is like i feel like they're
in middle school or something right i
think they're 14 yeah 15. but like
everyone talks like a [ __ ] poet you
know
i don't give a [ __ ] if you put him in
the school yeah you've got to write 13
year olds like 13 year olds so
corset was talking like [ __ ] mozart
was back then you know and it's like
dude you should be you're 15. when i was
15 all i was thinking about was poo poo
pee pee
that's all i think about that that's all
i think about now you know
so you are you you are way
way more sophisticated than you should
be for a few days yeah yeah yeah like
this this guy like came out of the womb
speaking in sonnets and all this [ __ ]
like he was studying shakespeare by the
age of three like mike i'm like my my
god like that that took me out so much
and uh it was a small thing but it was
just like you could have easily made
them at a higher age to make them feel
like they were you know they had the
ability to speak like this but it was
just they were 14 years old and that was
that was the biggest thing that uh just
it's annoying because sometimes it shows
where like they write their characters
like 17 year olds they act and talk like
17 year olds they they behave like 17
year olds why not just make them [ __ ]
17 that's that's why i think to this day
the most perfect uh example of like a
perfectly age uh and you know
characters acting age-appropriate in a
super realistic way was golden time
because it was like they were in college
and yet they were super immature like
most college students yeah yeah you know
like that's that's a realistic character
that's why i love golden yeah and that's
why that show was so good and it was so
immersive because it's like yeah i i
know people who are like this thing
you're such a breath of fresh air i have
seen in college yeah yeah yeah but they
were acting more like high school
students than most high school students
were yeah in other shows
and it's like that's so [ __ ] ironic
yeah like that's what i feel like that's
why to me even now golden time is like
one of my favorite romances
in all of anime just just because it
actually felt like these were believable
characters set in a world that felt like
it was based in reality yeah not in this
anime world where 15 year olds 15 year
olds are doing quantum physics 14 year
olds are doing quantum physics um like
[ __ ] i mean you look at [ __ ] like
naruto and sasuke like they used hunter
was another one where i felt like they
got the characters ages like actually
reflected their personality you know
yeah like gone was an idiot but like
like he he would like be convinced to do
stuff by strangers
no no one over the age of 18 is hanging
out with his soccer you know what i mean
like let's be honest for good reason
oh he's talking to me okay i'll talk
back you know i mean like i appreciate
it when shows like actually treat the
characters like their age yeah because
piss me off because like a lot of people
like for example naruto like a lot of
people forget that like in the og naruto
they're like he's like
they're 11 and 12 years old yeah and and
like you you look at some of the [ __ ]
they go through like sasuke's like
trying to revenge his entire [ __ ]
plan at the age of 11
11. he's he's wrong
he's doing that right
he's listening
no i don't know man i just i just kind
of wish that it would it would it would
change a little bit and you know and
that was one of the main reasons why i
was was a bit harsh on tokyo avengers
and that's why i got more annoyed at it
because it felt like it was just getting
stupid right now i mean i don't know if
i'm just like [ __ ] i've just seen so
adam so much anime that i'm just like
immune to this [ __ ] but just like it's
it's
it's it's very rare that a character's
age really comes into like any kind of
specific plot point or any bearing on
the plot itself because there's no like
it's so hard to tell a character's age
and anime based on just their looks and
their actions because the range the
range of anime characters from like 13
to [ __ ] 28. yeah they all look the
same and they all act the same it's it's
almost like kind of like japanese people
in real life
maybe that's why maybe that's why right
right they turn into adults yeah like
you look at it like you look at like a
japanese going you're like you can be 12
or 30. did you see this i'm kind of
afraid to ask anyway keeping on anime i
guess i guess i guess since since i
finally get to talk about anime
uh i guess uh it's like i didn't
actually watch much anime this previous
season because i don't think there was
actually much good things oh god don't
say that everyone get angry there's no
good enemy
yeah dude you don't learn my lesson
2021 well i think 2022 has been a pretty
weak year for
but like i guess like the only real
recommendation i i would have since you
were going through like last year uh is
uh ranking of kings that's literally the
last one i've been meaning to watch
everlasting
last year
i mean
it's continuing on to this year so last
last year was i mean it's a 23 episode
show so last year we only had like 12
episodes oh i mean i guess i'll just
wait then i'll yeah i'll like sweet
sauce finish yeah
i mean it's almost finished but i feel
like it's only gonna be a part one of
the story but yeah ranking kings is
[ __ ] incredible i've heard it's
amazing yeah it's like un unironically a
lot of people like you know maiden best
didn't watch it because it looked like a
children's cartoon i also didn't i
didn't i also didn't watch it because it
looked like a children's cartoon
initially but
it's kind of like
a it's kind of like the closest thing to
like a ghibli movie i guess in terms of
like aesthetic yeah
and i i really don't like ghibli movies
but it kind of gave me that kind of you
know you know when you're like watching
an anime fairy tale then yeah it kind of
feels like that's like
i can only point to ghibli that gives
you that same kind of feeling but that's
the kind of feeling it's giving me um
but it also is written really really
[ __ ] well like it's been a while
since i've seen just an anime just this
well written and with characters this
interesting as well damn um it's like
it's like
to me like the spring season sorry the
winter season was like basically attack
on titan and demon slayer everyone was
like talking about yeah but like to me
ranking of kings is like close to that
level of quality in my opinion of just
like how good the show is well i mean
there's also my dress up darling as well
there's also my dress-up darling but
that like that
that occupies a different space in my
opinion you know that's a different
faction yeah that's the definition
that's a different faction
there's the attack on titan demon slayer
like core and then the [ __ ]
microphone all the way over here yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah which is like it was
surprising to see like in in japan my
ranking of kings is really like shot up
in popularity
i think it's like the most watched anime
right now it's because there's a lot of
voice actors who are saying
how good it is so like they're like
they're all like yeah this is really
funny there's a lot of power here yeah